on the okay you have work to do yeah I
do notice that with you conservatives
now that I hang out with you people you
know don't think there's work thing come
on the water's nice Dave get on in here
wouldn't it be funny if I was actually
making you guys all more liberal even
know it could be you people a lot more I
know I feel I feel it happening by the
moment you know so you bring up science
yeah and that is everyone all talking
about science these days people I think
forget that the science Western science
is a product of the church basically
Copernicus was a priest
you know we they all knock the Catholic
Church because of Galileo but Galileo
was kind of a jerk man Church was very
nice to Copernicus the my question here
is some of the compelling arguments for
God these days are more science-based it
was a it was a Catholic priest who
discovered the Big Bang George Lemaitre
and he was mocked because people thought
there was a static universe the
Aristotelian universe but he said no it
had a beginning it was the Big Bang
there is one of the most compelling
arguments didn't get me but it's a
compelling one is fine-tuning that if
you change the calculations of of the
strong or weak nuclear forces by just
slight degrees the different different
forces in the universe life would be
impossible very minor measurements do
those scientific arguments the prime
mover you need a beginning a mover that
isn't contingent or physical hmm do any
of those move you toward a god that is
that has isn't just an unconscious thing
as you just said but has a teleology a
purpose behind it not really we we could
do this after a couple drinks not really
though I don't know that it is even part
of what the human experience is to
understand that I think we can do I
think there are people that are
religious that can spend their entire
lives trying to figure out what the
meaning of the universe is I think there
are scientists who can try to find the
god particle or you know figure out
through physics or mathematics what the
what the real design of the universe is
I think it is I think that actually is
much more of what being a human
about than knowing it I suspected
earlier
look maybe we will get to a point one
day where we will know there will be a
big booming voice in the sky that
everyone is gonna suddenly know and
maybe it'll be alien real but you know
what it could be you see it could be
aliens it could be you know I mean like
it depends how far you want to run with
all this but I would say that you're not
knowing outside of time and space it
could be I mean who knows maybe well
suddenly everyone was gonna wake up with
the big like G on their foreheads yeah
I'll go what happened there I know
because you know I'm sending you signers
I think but I would say that the
question of not knowing and being okay
with that and that not having that stunt
your growth as a human whether you want
to think of things in a religious way or
in a scientific way I think that that's
what being human is all about and you
should ideally you'd meld the 2d guy
thing a lot of people say that faith and
science are in conflict but of course
that is a very modern idea that none of
the founders of modern science would
have said that Newton spent 30 years of
his life interpreting Scripture yeah
well look I stein said you know God
doesn't play dice with the universe I
think that's an interesting way of
saying it because there's an implicit
belief there then he's saying well
something God he's saying God doesn't
and Einstein said George Lemaitre is big
bang theory it was so beautiful that's
why he would he was computer so simple
and so beautiful yeah it just all seems
kind of like smug and arrogant to me in
a way let's my what I prefer yeah that's
you seem very smug and arrogant
that's better than what I'm called on
Twitter I don't even want to look at
this Nina so there is that one final
argument yes one I don't think you could
possibly disagree with yeah this
argument is the argument errs
democratise the the argument is that
Hillary Clinton was supposed to hi
president Donald Trump is not supposed
to be present was a 99% chance that
Hillary was going to be President
according to Princeton University then
mate before the election yep then we got
Trump then and this is just my own
empirical observations my own
experiments a blank book making fun of
Democrats became the number one
bestseller in the world now ben shapiro
serenades my dates with roaming
millennial that tell me that God doesn't
exist tell me that it's impossible it's
impossible argument the mystery of the
versus infolding right in front of you
and you just got to keep rolling with
that but that doesn't prove that God
exists it just proves that the universe
is here and sometimes I think you're a
little more in line with it and
sometimes you're not you had a nice
little run here and Hillary Hillary was
not one your guy he was far away from
you got your Trump you got your book you
got your Shapiro you got your roaming
millennial but that just means you're
doing things you know like we always
find signs when it works to us but all
day long there are signs that have no
meaning it is a wicked generation that
looks for signs and wonders but it is a
stupid generation that ignores signs and
wonders I hope David I've saved your
soul